c'est étrange gallois d'entendre des
déclarations pareilles jusque c'est en
juillet de cette année je pense que le
new york times a publié ces informations
pour la première fois maille popeo
ensuite appelé sergueï lavrov notre
ministre des affaires étrangères et le
secrétaire américain à la défense a
contacté son homologue russe sergueï
choïgou après cela des responsables au
plus haut niveau militaire puis au
niveau des services spéciaux américains
ont déclaré qu'ils n'avaient aucune
confirmation sur des informations de ce
genre il est extrêmement étrange que
certains états unis lisent les journaux
mais ignorent les déclarations de la
responsable
c'est la première chose que je voudrais
bien deuxièmement on soutenait dès le
début la présence des troupes
américaines en afghanistan et nous avons
autrefois voté en faveur de la
résolution pertinente du conseil de
sécurité de l'onu dès j'estime toujours
que la présence des américains en
afghanistan ne va pas à l'encontre de
nos intérêts nationaux
au contraire quand on a appris que les
etats-unis se préparer à retirer leurs
contingents militaires de la ba notre
position officielle n'a pas changé cela
peut créer des conditions
supplémentaires pour une réconciliation
à taraf gad
même si personnellement je pense que
cela peut aussi comporter beaucoup de
risques